I give it a couple more years he's
already got cancer he's already got I
thought you said he was the cool one
dude if you're in a conversation with
them bro you're like shut up you talk so
slow too
[Music]
here's a pretty crazy story that has a
happy ending for once I like happy
endings it starts with a father and he's
got two sons
that father
there's a grandfather above him okay he
dies and leaves an inheritance to only
one of those Sons
ouch wait was it was it the father's
grandfather or his father's father's
father okay so it's the two boys
grandfather Yeah because there's
favoritism he's like use I hate this son
of a [__] but I like you I know it kind
of sounds like a Bible story in a way
yeah but yeah you have grandfather
father two sons The Inheritance skips
this father and goes to one of these
Sons okay so what does the father decide
to do himself but how do you do that you
kill both your sons you can't tell me
that one son yeah the one you already
got two sons just get rid of one yeah so
the father and the son that didn't get
it and the Holy Spirit
turned his brother and also with you the
father and the son hired a Hitman to
kill the other son that got the
inheritance yeah no wonder the [__]
grandfather didn't give it to the dad or
the son he's like these guys are [__]
yeah they must have been really [__] but
did they succeed so what happened is the
hit man that they ended up contacting
felt so disgusted by the deal they
killed them that he reported it to the
police that's so [__] he broke the
Hitman like this the Creed because he
was like this dude is really trying to
kill his own son for money yeah so what
do you expect though you're a hit man
like what do you think is gonna be all
happy go lucky hey but that's kind of
cool that he had a limit it's really
cool yeah yeah but now he's gonna get
gunned down by John Wick and the whole
[__] centennials or whatever dude he
was a hit come on man yeah so they were
gonna pay him 40K to do it it could have
been his first job too well he's all
like his son was only 40K in him yeah
what do you mean and the reason that the
FI the dad was so pissed about it and
the other son is that they're saying
that that brother they think that he did
something to the grandfather to persuade
him to give him the inherence but they
don't think it was a clean you know so
you kill him so that's like how you
either way yeah no bro this Hitman had a
heart and he was like wow I'm not doing
that Hitman with a heart yeah he found
him on Yelp or something Brent The
Hitman heart yeah
dude yeah dude I was reading this thing
about like what are some things that
people tell Hitman before they die and
then Hitman the hitmans were like I
don't know why a lot of people just
start telling me about their family yeah
and then they're like they're like oh
don't kill me I got kids I got a wife
because they're like your family hired
me
are like usually like we came from
badass families we don't like our
parents so it's like so it doesn't hit
I'm not gonna be sympathetic for you
because it's like I'm actually doing
your kids a favor because you're a piece
of [__] and I'm eliminating the piece of
[__] from the family so what should you
say to him you're like please don't kill
me I still have to kill my parents I
[__] hate them so much
I promise that's the father and the son
okay Holy Spirit not pictured they look
like yeah that's scary [__] Teriyaki
look at those eyes bro those [__]
eyes those eyes are nuts yeah does that
look like a wig I thought so too yes
does that look real I don't know he
looks like he's on something I want them
to put the face the facial hair together
like his hair on top
[Laughter]
did I happen to mention how much the
inheritance was no it's uh 40K 40. oh
actually they did it was like
yeah but it's it's two properties and
16k in cash I think so it's like a house
so wherever they're from looks like a
house is worth 40K though that's what
I'm saying
they're a little bit off the edge
they're a little down bad we're just
right watch the Sun be like the picture
of the sun's like in a suit he's like
all put together yeah um it'll be funny
if like slick dude the whole price of
the Hitman was the whole price of The
Inheritance that's what I'm saying or
more I know so you lose 10K you're like
I'll give you 50k
they're liking somewhere in Tennessee
where the homes are worth 30k I I think
it's I'll do a 40K I'll give you a
million Wisconsin uh Wisconsin is it
Wisconsin I don't know you would be able
to tell those are my people wait let me
see them again they're wisconsinites uh
it's in the town of Berlin not uh
Germany you know where that is no
[__] state is this wisconsinites
I thought you said Wisconsin no it's not
oh it is Wisconsin Berlin I swear it is
yeah damn I'm absolutely not a Wisconsin
Father and Son dude that's your people
what the [__] is that your uncle yeah is
it yeah I love Wisconsin's accent
I used to have one what was it does it
sound like um Lois uh from
um from Family Guy Family Guy yeah was
that Wisconsin or no or is that
Minneapolis
like the vowels are drowned out oh they
sound Canadian huh you don't know where
Berlin Wisconsin is nope so it's right
there to the left of Oshkosh Oshkosh
straight in the center right there
yo I used to have a sick ass pair of
OshKosh overalls dude this is a
particularly boring part of the video
and if you guys come back to it how did
this make you say that wait Zuma who am
I as a person
zoom out let's uh let's look at Berlin
Wisconsin it's north of Madison yeah so
I was current temperatures are ranging
in the 70s okay so that's not my that's
pretty far that's not my people Chris is
the only access that we have to the
Midwest right here so we have no idea
what to think about it it's north of
Madison okay I don't know what the [__]
that is but um Christians area is more
was it between Madison Milwaukee yeah I
was in a nice area you know I only know
about T-Pain's Mansion in Wisconsin
from Wisconsin
his lyrics are all right everybody's put
in the same scenario you have to accept
what's the least amount of money you
gotta accept inheritance to off with
your family members 2K
2K he's just talking about the game too
he just wants the game
[Laughter]
dude I already hate half of my family
I'll [__] kill him for free yeah okay
redacted
so tell me about your relationship
like you know what we can do to your
family and then they're all putting
threats on me and I'm like go right
ahead
He's fluffy I know right it's like
actually I've been waiting for someone
to do that for me but like I'm like what
would they do in your in in your whole
family in the order of like who you
really wouldn't miss who's number one
what do you mean like who's your number
one I wouldn't really care if you were
gone oh man that's there's so many
really
it's not a joke or is that really it's
super super pleasurable death like they
ever they coupon from an assassin and
he's like I'll do you one right now for
free oh really no at that point I'll be
I had to be like you know what
don't take this happiness away from me
what do you mean I gotta do it myself
but I think I don't know sounds like you
actually do love them yeah
I have to do it myself yeah it sounds
like you love them
that's cute okay Joe loves his family
[Laughter]
I don't think I'd be I'd be able to get
any of my family members that I do care
about assassinated it's too much money
but I'll tell you this I'll tell you
this though okay they're not even my
stepdad is about 88 years old I give it
a couple more years he's already got
cancer he's already got I thought you
said he was the cool one he's cool but
he talks too much so he's already got
cancer and he talks like dude if you're
in a conversation with them bro you're
like shut up you talk so slow too
he's 88. all right he's diabetic so
diabetic people probably should die uh
just kidding just kidding just kidding
I'm kind of partly I'm almost out of
diabetics I could say this
um
I'm pre-diabetic sickest excuse dude
uh and on top of that I mean he's got a
lot of things you know so if it had to
be someone I'm just saying like it had
to be it's like you're about to leave
bro I hope you never watched it he'll
watch it I'll send it to him directly
skipped it four minutes
[Laughter]
uh family member who just had he uh he
has heart problems he just went through
the hospital for that he's pretty old
too so I would say like when you're in
your 80s you probably could take one for
the family and I only say this because
if if it was me and I have my grandson
or whatever and I'm like man you guys
this money will do you so good like I'll
take it for the team because we
samuraize like that you know I was gonna
say it's Samurai like Japanese culture
isn't it super like we just can't wait
to die we just can't wait to die for
people that's the ultimate honor yeah so
I'm like I'm like two thousand dollars
got you bro you know
so next time when you're looking at only
fans and jacking off think of me because
I [__] paid for those bills oh wow
[Laughter]
[Music]